friend how long is too long to wait in a  situationship where it's just he doesn't  like you she's never being in a  situationship  okay fine everyone else  to my younger siblings or anything I'll  say at least if you're seeing a guy for  at least a minimum of nine months and he  hasn't made no like no indication that  he wants to make you his girl then yeah  you're just gonna have to keep it moving  otherwise he's going to be played the  fool because he's just running game on  you for me I'd have to cut I'd have to  run for three months I'd still have to  run with it again and I forgot did you  say it takes you three months or it  takes you longer than that yeah three  months oh you said three months okay